what is going on you think everyone's
eating each other like a any more
questions
hey i'm logan miller i'm joey Morgan
we're here to show you how to survive
the zombie apocalypse scouts guide to
the zombie apocalypse is about three Boy
Scouts who are unlikely heroes and
become a fighting funny force of three
awesome Scouts this is a gun of
sorts but I have turned it and Taylor
made it into a crossbow with you see a
metal ruler right here and we get some
of these Nine Inch Nails yeah I'm
talking to you Trent Reznor and we take
this throw it in there and boom right to
the head dude these zombies don't stand
a chance
Auggie has finessed his way to being
able to build basically a doorknob
shooter that has compressed air going
through and it's basically firing
through PVC pipe it blows up heads in
ways that you will never believe it's a
head blower it'll blow your mind
I think if I got my friends together we
put our minds to it I could definitely
make a weapon of sorts
maybe take some razor blade it's on the
top of a hockey stick like the tracks
some sort of like a snow blower like
some zombies our fastest of zombies can
run to you but the slow ones and you got
a little snow blower down there and just
take them out at the legs and then maman
over you know Oman over dude something's
wrong with it with your chest fellow
that makeup dummy the jungle